hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich glaube jeder von uns kennt
Netflix als App zum Filme und Serien
schauen allerdings ist mir etwas
aufgefallen und zwar kann man dort auch
Netflix Games spielen keine Werbung
extra Gebühren oder In-App-Käufe
unbegrenzter Zugriff auf exklusive
Spieler die in ihrer Mitgliedschaft
inbegriffen sind man schlagen die da
halt zahlreiche Spiele vor die man sich
runterladen kann und von daher dachte
ich mir teste heute mal gemeinsam diese
drei Spiele nimmst an einer neuen heißen
dating schaut Teil aber wirst du den
Versuchungen widerstehen können wenn
alle Regeln ins Spiel kommen wir müssen
jetzt erstmal unseren Namen eingeben und
dann müssen wir noch unser Pronomen
nehmen er sein sie ihr oder Ziel frag
mich da gar nichts mehr ich habe mich
jetzt mal so erstellt man hat ziemlich
wenig Auswahlmöglichkeiten und egal wie
man sich macht man sieht immer aus den
absolut Supermodel also wir starten
einfach mal rein willkommen im
tropischen Paradies das ist wohl unser
Hotel hier sieht schon krass aus wir
haben ja
sieht das alles cool aus genau das meine
ich die leicht im Wind wiegen den Palmen
scheinlich bei deiner Ankunft auf der
Insel zu begrüßen Sie den Strand an sie
dir den Pool an das wird der beste
Sommer aller Zeiten 12 Stunden
man spielt einfach die Torte Ende
Staffel nach du siehst dich umtank
sonnen und machst dich mit deiner
Umgebung vertraut eine Auswahl an teurem
Champagner steht auf einem Tisch eiskalt
glitzert er im Sonnenlicht es wäre eine
Schande ihn ganz alleine zu genießen
fragst dich ob du dir ein Glas nehmen
und ein Schluck gönnen sollst aber dann
siehst du auf einer
arbeitsprachen lernen Babbel
[Musik]
Yogalehrerin
ihre Augen lohnen wie Feuer als ich eure
Blicke treffen und es fühlt sich so
intensiv an dass dir fast der Mund offen
steht Bro die ist jetzt nicht so ganz
mein halb oh wow wenn alles Single so
aussehen dann bin ich in Schwierigkeiten
vor dir stehen und die erste Sache die
dir auffällt ist ihre niedliche Art na
du schöner oh mein Gott
[Musik]
während ihr hypnotisch tschüss
ach jetzt kann ich erstmal ein bisschen
bestimmen ich kann jetzt entweder
Antworten freut mich du bist
beeindruckend oder die Party geht jetzt
los natürlich geht die Party los ja wie
jetzt zu zweit sind würde ich sagen dass
die Party jetzt losgeht ich bin übrigens
Luca ein wunderschöner Name für eine
wunderschön
die schnappt sich ein Champagnerglas und
blickt auf das schaumige Meer hinaus die
Wellen küssen den Strand dieser Ort ist
unglaublich und der Strand ist perfekt
um dort Yoga zu machen
betrachtest die neugierig während Sie
die Aussicht genießt Yoga ist das dein
Ding meine Leidenschaft ja ich bin
Yogalehrerin sie dreht den Stil des
Glases
also
Strohhalm habe ich schon mal Yoga
gemacht ein paar Mal nie mache ich an
alter das ist mein zweiter Vorname ich
bin praktisch Profi ja wirklich
vielleicht kannst du mir das dabei ja
morgens vielleicht kannst Du mir da aber
ich kann echt nicht mehr lesen ne die
Leute dich an und ihr Blick lässt dein
Herz rasen namasté
[Musik]
du wirst abgelenkt als du jemanden
hinter ihr bemerkst oder kommt jetzt
noch mehr oder was ein sehr attraktiver
Kerl kommt ah Konkurrenz
Liam
Rolex
[Musik]
börsenanlegerprofi woW hat der einsberg
Konkurrenz abchecken sie dir den an auf
sein Gesicht konzentrieren da ich
allerdings eh nicht auf die Marisa
wirklich stehe kann ich ihr schon diesen
hier ein bisschen schmackhaft reden und
mach einfach mal diese Ideen an ich will
jeden einzelnen Bauchmuskel zählen mit
meiner
okay er geht mit einem großen Lächeln im
Gesicht auf dich und Marisa zu was geht
ab ihr heißen Singles ich bin Leon hey
Liam ich bin Marisa Marisa streckt ihre
Hand aus aber er fängt ab
er hat Bock auf die lass das doch ich
bin mehr der Drucker komm her er lacht
während immer Riesa umarmt aber als er
sich dir zuwendet verdunkeln sich seine
Augen mit unmissverständlicher
Entschlossenheit und wen haben wir hier
ich bin Luca
stell dir mal vor der steht auf mich und
ich bin dein wahr gewordener Traum der
Mittelpunkt der Party Single und bereit
mich unter die Leute zu mischen ich ähm
sag einfach mal ich bin seit war
geworden wenn du mir mit deinem Blick
irgendetwas sagen willst du lächelst ihn
flirten an Liam grinst und
selbstbewusst hmm versteckst ein Lächeln
indem du einen Schluck Champagner nimmst
ey die Marisa muss ich noch so viel am
Platz
wird das hier bevor wir uns aber
weiterhin das Netflix Spiel Tour
generell einstürzen würde ich sagen
testen wir noch die anderen beiden
diese Musik ist so pur Spongebob hier
arbeiten einfach nur an einem Stand der
Krossen Krabbe vor den Häusern von
Thaddäus Patrick und SpongeBob und
müssen die Sachen machen ich packe jetzt
hier den Teig drauf eine Kaffeetasse ist
schon fertig die hat das schon beim
links beim Kaffee müssen wir auch noch
warten rechts der Teig ist auch fertig
den kriegt er auf jeden Fall wieder Teig
drauf aber wir können sogar doppelteig
machen hier noch eine Tasse Kaffee
müssen wir jetzt direkt wieder warten
bis der Teig fertig ist die anderen
beiden haben wir noch nicht
freigeschaltet guck mal hier kommt der
zack zack drauf nicht der das und das
und jetzt müssen wir wieder auf den Teig
warten der Kaffee ist hier schon fertig
hier vorne rechts der Teig ist fertig
Bam Bam zack das ist ja ein übelst
langweiliges Spiel
ähm ich würde sagen wir spielen jetzt
mal das letzte Spiel und zwar müssen wir
hier eine eigene Farbe aufbauen bei
country friends road rage oder irgendwie
so heißt das heißt ich brauche deine
Hilfe um die Farben wieder zum Laufen zu
bringen keine Sorge ich helfe dir aber
hör auf zu quatschen bitte zack Denise
erstmal ernten das ist ja genauso wie
ist ja genau wie hay day das ist ja eins
zu eins hay day Fake hay day fand ich
auch früher so geil ich schwöre euch
wenn Gartenarbeit generell so gewesen
wäre ne das wäre ein Traum aber gut wir
pflanzen jetzt auf jeden Fall unseren
Mais an streuen das hier hin
beschleunigen das ganze ich war auch
früher so ein Fuchs da haben die nicht
bei hay day gesagt oder auch bei clash
of Clans so ja gib jetzt mal einen Juwel
aus oder ein
Smaragd damit du es halt ein bisschen
beschleunigen kannst
ich habe schon im Tutorial die 30
Sekunden gewartet damit ich einen mehr
habe
guck mal fertig
gesagt habe ich nur Bock auf Handyspiel
weil ich wissen will wie es mit Marisa
und Liam weiter läuft
nochmal ganz kurz rein dann erzähl uns
mal was über dich hier ich bin
Aktienhändler ich hatte noch etwas
Urlaub aufgespart und konnte deshalb
hier teilnehmen und warum verbrauchst du
deine Urlaubstage für eine datingshow
bereitet seine Arme aus und beginnt zu
gehen
sie dich mal um Sonne Sand sexy Singles
und Luca
also ich zähle ja zu den sexy Single
sieht aus als ob du einfach eine gute
Zeit haben willst ich bin definitiv auf
eine gute Zeit aus nicht mehr und nicht
weniger bevor du antworten kannst nähern
sich noch zwei weitere Personen der
Gruppe und wenn ihr wissen wollt werde
ich jetzt zwei Personen das sind meine
Damen und Herren lass mal einen Daumen
hoch unter dem Video hier da abonniert
meinen Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke
um weitere Videos nicht zu verpassen
soll ich eventuell dieses Tour zu
händelspiel weiterspielen schreibt sie
gerne unten in die Kommentare ich muss
jetzt erstmal aber brutal kacken weil
ich halt einfach keine Ahnung jeder
Mensch muss kacken